am Morgen begrüßte Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz den israelischen
Ministerpräsidenten Herzog am
Bundeskanzleramt sein erster
Staatsbesuch in Berlin und dazu sprechen
wir jetzt mit unserer bildchef
Reporterin Antonia Jamin vor dem
Bundeskanzleramt wie schwer war dieses
Treffen für Bundeskanzler Scholz zuletzt
gab es ja Irritationen als der
palästinensische Präsident Abbas im
Kanzleramt den Holocaust relativierte
und Scholz nicht sofort dazwischen
gingen gab es heute noch mal eine
Entschuldigung von Scholz
also da davor müssen wir tatsächlich
noch warten aber ich kann tatsächlich
sagen dass der Empfang natürlich sehr
formell war der Bundeskanzler es wird
bestimmt ein Thema sein der
Bundeskanzler wird sich auch
wahrscheinlich wieder entschuldigen die
beiden der Präsident die Track Herzog
und der Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz sie
kennen sich ja noch nicht das ist
eigentlich ihr erstes Treffen gestern
hat der israelische Präsident israk
Herzog hier in Berlin gelandet sein
erster Ziel das erste Ziel war Schloss
Bellevue da hat er sein Amtskollege
Präsident Frank-Walter Steinmeier sofort
begrüßt das war natürlich sehr herzlich
da hat man auch auf dieses formelle
handschütteln verzichtet die haben sich
sofort umarmt die sind Freunde die
kennen sich schon über zehn Jahre mit
dem Kanzler ist es eine andere
Geschichte das ist das erste Mal dass
sie sich treffen und tatsächlich ist die
Truck Herzog der erste hochrangige
israelische Staatsvertreter der den
Bundeskanzler auch jetzt trifft nach
diese ab was Geschichte erst vor zwei
Wochen der Kanzler wird sich
wahrscheinlich wieder entschuldigen der
Kanzler hat ja hat sich ja schon
entschuldigt auch bei uns bei Bild auch
auf den sozialen Medien auch beim
Premierminister von Israel am Telefon
aber jetzt halt
persönlich auch beim Präsidenten heute
gedenkt man in Deutschland den Opfern
des Terroranschlags bei den Olympischen
Spielen von 1972 in München das ist der
50 Jahrestag wie geht es heute weiter
für den Bundeskanzler und auch für den
israelischen Präsidenten
ja also dazu muss man ja sagen man hat
in Deutschland war was waren wir jetzt
kurz vor eine Blamage die wurde jetzt
letzte Minute behoben weil die elf
Familien von den Angehörigen ja jetzt
schon in München sind der Präsident wird
später heute noch hier beim
Brandenburger Tor besuchen und von hier
geht es dann sofort zum Flughafen und
mit dem Präsident von Deutschland mit
Frank Walter Steinmeier fliegen sie
zusammen nach München zu der
Gedenkzeremonie bei Fürstenfeldbruck und
wir sind natürlich mit dabei du hast
auch selbst Angehörige der Opfer und
Überlebende des Attentats getroffen was
waren das für Momente für dich
das war natürlich sehr berührend wir
haben mit allen quasi gesprochen wir
haben mit den Witwen gesprochen die 50
Jahre davor gekämpft haben die Wahrheit
ins Licht zu bringen wir haben mit
schauler Dani gesprochen ein Holocaust
Überlebenden denn auch die Olympischen
Spielen 72 überlebt hat und wir haben
sogar mit dem letzten Geisel also der
einzige Geisel der auch Geisel war und
hat uns geschafft hat zu flüchten
gesprochen 50 Jahre danach ist der
Schmerz immer noch sehr sehr Präsenz wir
haben eine tolle Doku bei BILD.de sollte
man sich auch mal anschauen heute um 19
Uhr sehen wir diese Doku vielen Dank für
den Moment Antonia Jamin
ja und schaula Dani als Kind hat er den
Holocaust überlebt 72 kam mehr als
Spitzenathlet nach München zu den
Olympischen Spielen und dachte in diesem
neuen Deutschland kann ihm nichts mehr
passieren
es ist der fünfte september
1972 als palästinensische Terroristen
brutal die Wohnungen der israelischen
Delegation im Olympischen Dorf in
München überfallen in einer der
Wohnungen schläft auch schauladani er
hat den Holocaust überlebt bei den
Olympischen Spielen 1972 entkommt er nur
knapp dem Tod
Show ist mehrfacher israelischer
Landesmeister im Gehen noch heute mit 86
Jahren beginnt für ihn jeder Tag mit
Lauftraining okay was machen wir jetzt
wie viel laufen wir fünf Kilometer fünf
Kilometer es ist 6 Uhr morgens
bild-chefreporterin Antonia Jamin
versucht mitzuhalten
eine Stunde und fünf Kilometer später
ist das Training vorbei
all diese Pokale gehören Ihnen all diese
und es gibt noch viele andere die nicht
hier stehen ich schätze dass ich
ungefähr 800 Pokale besitze
Preise für schaue den großen Sportler
und Weltrekordhalter im Gehen lange vor
seinen Siegen 1941 Schaul ist fünf Jahre
alt
überfällt Nazi-Deutschland Jugoslawien
unverzüglich wollen sie das Land
judenfrei haben
etwa zehn Tage später wurden in Belgrad
bereits plakata an Hauswänden aufgehängt
auf denen alle Juden aufgefordert wurden
zu einem bestimmten Zeit an einem
bestimmten Ort zu erscheinen im zweiten
Absatz stand Juden die den Anweisungen
nicht folgen werden erschossen meine
Eltern beschlossen zu fliehen und die
Donau zu überqueren nach Budapest
die Familie ladani flüchtet nach Ungarn
aber drei Jahre später steht die SS vor
der Tür die Familie wird im Fieber Gong
ins Konzentrationslager Bergen-Belsen
deportiert
das ist die Baracke in der ich war und
da kann man einen Teil des Wachturms
sehen und das Hakenkreuz
ist es nicht schwer für sie ich habe das
durchgemacht es ist Teil meiner
Geschichte
durch einen Gefangenenaustausch werden
Schaul und seine Eltern freigelassen
dann der Weg ins gelobte Land
später Schaul besucht den Israel die
Universität startet er seine gärlaufbahn
sie führt den 1972 zu den Olympischen
Spielen nach Deutschland
ich hatte Nationalstolz ich dachte wir
zeigen der Welt und Deutschland dass wir
obwohl sie versucht haben uns zu
eliminieren hier sind und in der Lage
sind und der ganzen Welt auf dem
gleichen Niveau wie alle Weltsportler zu
stellen
schaule Arndt nicht das 28 Jahre nach
dem Holocaust Juden in Deutschland immer
noch nicht sicher sind am 5 september
1972 wird er aus dem Schlaf gerissen
gegen halb sechs Uhr morgens weckte man
mich und dann sagte mir man hat Moni ein
Sportler in der Delegation ermordet ohne
viel nachzudenken steckt sich meine Füße
in die Sportschuhe ich bin immer noch im
Pyjama aber gehe zu Haustür und öffnet
sie
rechts von mir am Eingang zur Wohnung
Nummer 1 steht jemand er trägt eine
Sturmhaube und schaut gerade aus
vor ihm stehen vier Wachleute des
Olympischen Dorfes alle unbewaffnet und
den pastellfarbener Kleidung unter ihnen
eine Frau sie bittet den maskierten dem
Roten Kreuz zu erlauben einzutreten und
jemanden zu helfen sie sagte ihm er
solle menschlich sein er antwortet die
Juden sind auch nicht menschlich
ist auch als Geise genommen zu werden
fliehen schaulz Mitbewohner schaue warnt
noch den Delegationsleiter in Wohnung
Nummer 5 zusammen entkommen sie über den
Balkon
mein Charakter wurde halt durch den
Holocaust geprägt
ich habe so viel durchgemacht und ich
denke dass ich ein Stück weit immun
geworden bin
am frühen Morgen sind 11 von Shows
Sportkameraden tot
aber die Olympischen Spiele in
Deutschland sollen weitergehen
die Sportler kehren nach Hause zurück 11
von ihnen in Sergen für schaue eine kaum
zu ertragende Niederlage die Note
arabische Länder haben jahrelang
versucht und von allen möglichen
sportforen auszuschließen und hier
nachdem Sie unser Blut vergossen
befriedigen wir unsere Feinde und
verlassen das olympische Forum und
verschwinden wenn
Schaul lebt und atmet Geschichte seine
ganz private aber auch die seines Volkes
sein Haus ist voller Erinnerungen die
Vitrine seiner Tante sie wurde von den
Nazis ermordet der alte Konzertflügel
seiner Eltern den sich die Nachbarn
einfach nahmen als die Familie ladani
ins Ghetto ging
aber da sind auch schools Pokale und
Trophäen sie glänzen hinter Glas sie
erinnern ihn für immer daran dass das
jüdische Volk niemals aufgibt
wenn ich falle komme ich wieder hoch
immer
bis jetzt ja
[Musik]